of the brewery business certainly been
known as male dominated a male-dominated
field and women especially women of
color have always faced some barriers a
local non-profit Works to try and help
them start brewing Lauren negretti live
this morning with lifting Lucy and how
it's being honored during Black History
Month Lauren good morning good morning
that's right non-profit lifting Lucy
supports black indigenous and all women
of color and beer industry events and
education opportunities now their
mission continues through the help of
athletic Brewing Company picking Lefty
lifting Lucy to receive a portion of the
proceeds from its Black History Month
special
lifting Lucy is working to change the
Beer World our mission is to support all
women of color in the craft beer
industry when it comes to attending
industry events and educational
opportunities
accepting Lucy has lent out a helping
hand toward North 5th Brewing Company it
is North Las Vegas's first and only
Craft brewery Ashley Randolph with
lifting Lucy for her to be the first
woman of color to open up a brewery and
the only Brewery in North Las Vegas
there's no way that I couldn't support
her 2021 data from the Brewers
Association shows nearly 9 000 craft
breweries of that nine to three percent
are under white ownership overall less
than three percent are owned fully by
women it's even less for people of color
a lot of the sales reps that come in
they will feel more comfortable talking
to my brother than they will to me or if
my brother's not there they will say
things like well why don't we wait till
he gets here or is the head Brewer here
maybe he can help me with this and I'm
like hey dude I'm the one that makes all
this I'm the one that signs the check
Amanda Pion and her brother Matthew two
Hispanic beer enthusiasts opened North
fifth Brewing Company at the end of
2021. last year lifting Lucy gave them a
grant to submit their beer into the
Great American Beer Festival even though
they didn't win on a national level with
those judges to get their feedback was
was priceless to us now lifting Lucy is
getting help they were selected to
receive some of the profits from
athletic brewing companies Black History
Month special Soul Sauer a non-alcoholic
Brew cheers
Randolph says they'll use the funds to
continue their mission making sure
finances don't stop a woman from
succeeding we really want to remove that
doubt for any woman of color that's in
the industry
and lifting Lucy will host its first
house of Lucy in May covering lodging
for up to nine women of color to attend
this year's craft Brewers conference in
Nashville live in The Newsroom Lauren
negretti 8 news now Lauren thank you
very much it's it's business you know
yeah it's like that name too